il paraît qu'il fait chaud nous tenons à
préciser qu'il s'agit des mises
enregistrées enfin nous voulons faire
tout de même des parfait glacé groupe
devrait déjà donner cette recette mais
oui catherine j'en ai déjà donné mais je
crois qu'on va demander c'est une des
émissions qu'elle vendait le plus de
précisions or justement j'ai faut que je
fasse des précisions à nouveau que j'en
donne à nouveau ce que je m'en vais les
donner à nous c'est à dire oui beaucoup
l'avait ratée pour un simple que pendant
qu' il y avait quelque chose que j'avais
omis de dire en réalité le nom qu il
faut faire bien attention simplement à
la façon de procéder et ça je crois que
c'est important
et puis vous nous avez donné une autre
recette de glace ah oui oui je voudrais
donner d'autres recettes aux gazaouis
ainsi plusieurs fois c'est bien celle ci
se fait uniquement avec des oeufs
n'est ce pas des ouvrages mais de
l'autre glace et de dents voyez vous je
des temps là la crème de lait que je
viens de mettre ici que je n'ai pas
mesuré je n'ai pas mesuré mais nous
allons donner la quantité la quantité
est de 3 jaunes et 150 g de sucre pour
un demi-litre de mélange c'est à dire un
tiers de litre de crème et le reste en
faisant la moitié n'est ce pas de dos
d'autres très glacée un tiers des
niveaux mieux mettre de l'eau que du
lait d'ailleurs redit bien lorsque
matière de litres de mélange de mélange
c'est-à-dire crème et aux la production
entre les deux c'est selon là et bien
vous savez nous avons presque toujours
ici de la crème épaisse par conséquent
la proportion est deux tiers de crème
pour un tiers d'eau
et ceci pour un demi-litre même pas de
mélange que l'on couette comme je vais
le faire maintenant
les trois jours ou 3 john et 125 g de
sucre ceux ci vont ils alors je m'en
débarrasser
commence alors le procédé est au départ
la crème doit être faite sur de la glace
alors il vaut mieux la portée sur la
glace elles montrent beaucoup plus vite
et plus ferme
alors nous allons le faire vous savez
qu'il fait très chaud ici par conséquent
nous avons nous nous ne sommes pas du
tout comment dirais-je influencé par la
chaleur extérieure va justement
non c'est gênant enfin en l'occurrence
il n'y a pas de question nous avons de
la glace dessous la ferme elle même
était très glacée l'eau comme vous avez
pu le voir été gâtés puisque les prises
au milieu des cubes de glace absolument
évidemment il y avait des moyens
l'abattre avec des appareils ménagers et
je ne suis pas absolument content mais
ces appareils ménagers ou possible
d'arrêter une seconde rotation du buzz
et ça c'est un cas très attention
beaucoup de gens justement ne font la
remarque suivante et oui monsieur lui en
avons essayé mais c'est embêtant savez
on a fait du beurre oui bien sûr et
notre parti s'est pas assez fou était
basse c'est embêtant aussi parce qu'ils
ont ce soir et pour se centrer faire ça
c'est un problème de la crème chantilly
c'est le problème c'est le problème
entier de la crème chantilly
car ce n'est pas autre chose que de la
crème chantilly alors voyez vous je
pense que c'est travers une émission
aujourd'hui un peu fastidieuse mais une
émission très intéressante pour les gens
qui veulent faire de la glace chez eux
sont sans avoir besoin d'une sombre qui
est sérieux de la grèce qui se fait
automatiquement dans un appareil ménager
réfrigérateur ordinaire alors je vous
donnerai si on compare les auditeurs
d'être fastidieux parce que en réalité
là c'est vraiment la façon de procéder
qui est importante par conséquent plus
oui je le crois je le crois
effectivement je crois que ce sont des
émissions qui sont vraiment très utile
celle là il y en a d'autres qui le sont
peut-être loin mais celle là est très
utile parce que j'avais vu la dernière
fois moulante et ça fait déjà très
longtemps qu'il est probable que nous
avons acquis beaucoup de nouveaux
téléspectateurs depuis mai effectivement
il faut que ces émissions là soit
extrêmement précises pour que chacun
sache le faire ensuite
vous avez trop de trop de chantiers pour
l'annoncer notre hélas non jeudi à l'ats
pascal en effet la chantilly monde
relativement très peu elle montre
beaucoup
si on a un appareil spécial qui insuffle
de l'air c'est un genre de moulins
colloïdal qui insuffle de l'air en même
temps que il faut être la crème alors on
obtient des crèmes extrêmement légère ce
que c'est c'est bien je dirais c'est
bien mais c'est quand même là doivent
être reposée parce qu'il faut qu'un lot
qui est dedans se dépose alors tout
compte fait vous savez ça revient à peu
près au même non je fais puis alors ce
que je connais mon appareil qui coûte
cher et difficile à manipuler que alors
ça ce sont des choses qui se passent de
coûts de conversion avec le petit jean
louis alors la voyez vous au fond nous
avons la démonstration suivante je pense
qu'il est important c'est que nous
pouvons toujours opérer sans aucun
appareil spécial
nous avons un fou et ça en fait c'est
quelque chose de très simple le avons
toujours et puis nous allons faire deux
recettes différentes
c'est à dire une recette qui sera faite
à base de jaune jaune sirop ou bien
liqueurs et jaune et sucre mélangées et
battus à chaud une rotation est une
recette à froid qui est la recette la
plus simple qui existe il a donné quoi
les deux vous donner les deux pour
l'instant vous avez commencé c'est le
même processus départ pour lui ni pour
l'autre c'est le même processus au
départ pour une épaule est seulement ici
et vous jure que montre le plus grand
c'est parfait alors oui mais voilà
maintenant ça y est que la mâche
antilles c'est la crème chantilly pour
ne pas pourrir marcus que très bien elle
est bien voyez vous les faire je vais la
mettre simplement dans le réfrigérateur
on sait par utilement fait je vais la
mettre pendant le temps que je vais
faire autre chose ce qui fait très chaud
ici risquer de tomber
non non on ne risque rien du tout
surtout quand le ciel est dans le dans
la glace c'est une précaution que je
répondre pour la protéger des sunlights
jusque là
à strictement que la traîne et l'eau bon
alors je la reçois ferait un tout petit
peu tout à l'heure mais maintenant voyez
vous l ai déjà très belle aie aie
regardez bon eh bien je m'excuse de ce
sept longueurs je vais la mettre dans le
réfrigérateur et maintenant vous allez
prendre quoi vos yeux c'est maintenant
l'intervention des oeufs
oui je m'en vais je donc pas besoin de
ça oui je vais en avoir besoin dans
quelques secondes
ici j'ai pesé 125 g de sucre je voulais
dit tout à l'heure il s'agit de 125
grammes et trois jours alors aussi
bassine en cuivre est indispensable non
on ne pourrait battre dans d'autres
choses mais moi je préfère battre dans
du cuivre ainsi installée parce que je
suis sûr d'aller vite et d'avoir un
résultat que je recherche c'est à dire
avec une apprécié malgré un guitariste
d'un film nous voulons tout de même
faire relativement sans solution de
continuité c'est à dire sans nous
arrêter et reprendre jusqu'au bout et
vous alors ici trois jaunes oui mais
vous savez celles à l'époque de la ponte
des poules à lomé où ici je vais
appliquer en assez grande quantité c'est
à dire une grosse aucune liqueur à base
de d'orange grand saut et je mélange
surcroît you sur le coup d'ailleurs à
lui
ce soir là je sais le nom là bas s'il
est bien gelée donner davantage
je vous conseille de faire très
attention et faussaire tout le monde
faire très attention aussi à l'emploi
cette méthode je suis que qu'elle songe
à l'emploi tout le monde en pleurs à la
seconde méthode que je vais vous
démontrer dans quelques secondes pour
toi parce que c'était facile et ce qu'on
fait il ya une économie un employé s'est
ainsi celle que le fait actuellement un
rendement meilleur point de vue quantité
mais l'autre tellement plus facile pour
tout le monde à la fois des langues et
nous avons des amis qui aime la
difficulté à le poivre mais c'est très
bien aussi
alors nous trois alors pure bien
l'intention lui revient à partir bien
sûr il est nécessaire d'avoir un énorme
non je n'ai pas si vous avez utilisé
l'autre tout à l'air alors voyez vous
cette du cantique et là ça aussi je mens
devons le dire de quoi cet ex entité la
courbière à deux tiroirs de cela
travailler à réfléchir un peu ordinaire
ménagers de tiroirs 404 personnes
procureur vraiment qu'aucun belge est
aussi brûlé favoris même chose c'est
suffisant comme chaleur mais ce qu'on
pourrait faire ça dans une casserole
tout bêtement une casserole c'est
beaucoup mais un appareil volé on peut
le faire
oui pourquoi en vue d'asseoir ce
possible
parce que je vois que ça prend médias et
où ça devient ça devient faire en
quelque sort alors je mens je continue à
battre puis je vais refroidir les chats
normalement je vais vous croyez moi dans
la glace mais normalement beaucoup et
laisser refroidir ses loisirs
opéré à l'enlever au lieu de faire un
peu mais je viens de faire c'est à dire
comment ces papous et et la trêve pour
commencer le haut à l'envers c'est à
dire vous prêtez d'abord ce que l'on
peut appeler du sahara yom cdu savions
ce que je suis en train de faire et une
fois que ça vaille on est prêt le
laisser refroidir pendant ce temps là
monter la crème
moi j'ai eu une autre raison de pertes
c'est une question 2 minutes 1 je suis
obligé de faire très attention pour
tomber exactement et la crème
je ne sais jamais combien de temps à mes
parents dit ça je sais pourquoi j'ai
commencé par faire ce qui est en quelque
sorte de mettre un peu la sellette avant
les boeufs honda ceci juste parce que ça
fait assez longtemps que ce soit très
homogène et légèrement gonflé légèrement
montrer c'est en amont tant que l'on en
tient justement une certaine légèreté
que l'autre système ne peux pas vous
donner c'est pourquoi j'insiste sur le
fait que je sais mais celui là est même
mieux que les jets et puis aussi c'est
une réussite presque certains l'autre
l'autre il faut faire très attention
quand aux dosages sens à civaux sucré
trop et ça ne prend pas et ceci je la
seule raison pour laquelle je ne crois
fonctionne cela peut ne pas prendre ces
dérogations sur les mains mais la raison
pour laquelle savent que le patron c'est
parce que c'est trop sucré c'est à dire
parce que vous n'avez pas mis ou
suffisamment de crème ou que cette crème
n'était pas assez léger tout est là il
n'y a pas d'autre il n'ya pas d'autre
secret en quelque sorte
raté raté oui raté vise à réussir ce
n'était pas ferme ça ça faisait de la
glace monette qui ne leur plaisait pas
et il avait d'ailleurs raison que
j'avais raison
ça doit être très très faire bon et bien
ici je vais mettre cet appareil puisque
ça s'appelle à partir de maintenant un
appareil l'instant il ya bilan et où je
vais j'y vais très bien regardé comme un
effet le ruban c'est ce qu'on appelle
faire le ruban c'est ce qu'ils font
alors il faut arriver à ça plus vous
mettrez deux liqueurs en quantité ou de
l'eau si vous voulez si vous ne voulez
pas mettre beaucoup de liqueur si vous
préférez par exemple mais trois aces 2
citons un geste d'orange comme parfum h
est très très faim vous pourrez le faire
et les allez vous remplacer si vous
remplacez la quantité d'alcool que je
gémis la dame par un liquide par de
l'eau pas trop liquide de long un peu de
sirop de quelque chose aussi citron par
exemple ou quelque chose comme ça ça
n'est pas embêtant économique nous avons
déjà côté alcool qui est utile non
entrés en partie parce que côté parfums
et les liquides bien sûr les eaux alors
cette quantité de jaune et de sucre qui
est un sabayon
je le mets avant refroidir normalement
si je n'avais pas cet inconvénient c'est
là qu'ils pouvaient laisser refroidir
tranquillement le mélange jeu pourrait
le laisser dans son bolide n'a pas
laissé longtemps qu être une question de
temps on est là au contraire je m'en
vais accélérer il refroidit accélérer le
refroidissement un petit peu
voilà vous joué jusque là alors nous
avons utilisé tout ce que vous nous avez
dit d'avoir oui oui parfaitement
il a besoin de rien d'autre absolument
rien d'autre absolument rien ceci va
refroidir tout doucement et maintenant
refroidie je m'en vais donc opérer la
seconde manière seconde manière je
préfère opéré dans un si vous voulez si
vous voulez n'y a pas de y'a pas dans
l'ue dont 80 pour le sucre bon eh bien
nous allons opérer maintenant alors là
je vais vous faire une petite diversion
en quelque sorte je vous parlais des
quantités de sucre nécessaire je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure que pour bien réussir
il fallait pas trop sucré
ça c'est d'une importance absolument
capital il n'y a rien qui gênent plus
que le taux de sucre bon eh bien nous
allons imaginer que nous n'avons pas de
quoi peser ce qui est tout à fait dans
le nanar les choses possibles on peut
très bien avoir
on peut très bien avoir un réfrigérateur
et pas de balancer ça c'est ça fait
partie tout à fait les choses normales
alors c'est ce système que je crois que
tout le monde emploiera etc pour lequel
je vais insister le plus alors vous
commencez par les gens ça y est très
attentif soyons alors les jeunes il en
faut vous savez que pour 2 2 tiroirs
normaux il vous en faut environ 3,3
jeudi environ parce que vous m'avez fait
remarquer tout à l'heure que c'est eux
était petit n'est ce pas vous avez
minimiser ça a été la maison à mes 4
alors non non j'en mettrais quand même
pas quatre mais je vais vous faire avoir
en mx2 qui s'est écrasé alors j'ai à oui
ça faisait drôle vous aviez déjà free
bon alors nous en avons mis trois et
nous allons mettre dessus alors c'est là
où justement intervient intervient le
système s'emballe ans alors je vais
maintenant du sucre là comme ceci je
suis sûr qu'avec cette quantité là je
n'ai pas assez alors je m'en vais faire
absorber
vous savez c'est très important faire
absorber le sucre par les gens petit à
petit il ne faut pas aller trop vite si
on a fait trop rire 6,7 cette opération
avait lieu trop vite on brûle les jaunes
on les cuit ils sont absolument cuisse a
fait des embrouilles et c'est assez
curieux de penser que parfois comme ça
le sucre cuit les jaunes si on ne
perdent trop rapidement alors je vous
avais dit qu'il n'avait pas d'assez vous
voyez que c'est vrai
là l'équipe se fait que c'est beaucoup
trop liquide cet appareil là est
beaucoup trop d'équipés
je vais donc ajouter du sucre jusqu'à ce
qu'il soit à peu près cela attention il
y tout de même la main légère car vous
nous avez bien mis en garde
voilà voilà alors là voyez vous la sagne
et nous avons l'épaisseur voulu c'est à
dire la voilà à peu près cette fois ci
ce temps alors là je dois travailler
alors ça c'est très important ça ne peut
plus se passer pas que ce moment que ces
mélanges et c'est fini c'est en le
mélangeant sac ou alors la voyez où je
m'en vais travailler avant c'est très
important
on appelle ça blanchir effectivement si
vous regardez ça blanchi regarder aller
c'est un curieux dont le voit on le voit
venir on va blanchir les gens ou et
liouize à tout le monde connais ça
alors vous allez vous travailler ça très
très très énergiquement car ça il faut
absolument que ce soit très bien
travaillé mais par contre voyez vous je
m'aperçois d'un petit défaut il faut que
je vous ai signalé six jeunes avec un
demi litre de crème pour ces jeunes là
il faudrait qu'il sait tenir deux
militants des crèmes soit très bien
monté si par contre cette crème n'est
pas très bien montée j'en ai trop
pourquoi je le vois parce que voyez vous
j'ai probablement utilisé au maximum la
la possibilité l'absorption du sucre que
là et je l'aimé trop
c'est à dire qu'il y aurait là taux de
sucre spurs âgées le voile est tombé je
suis tombé dans l'excès moi-même cesse
mais je le vois je le comprends alors je
vous le signale vaio autrement dit là il
aurait suffi de deux jours comme quoi
c'est je n'étais pas si petit vous
voulez bien le sais parce que vous les
avez alors je compte travailler
j'insiste j'insiste sur le fait que ses
recettes au point de vue quantités sont
pas absolument rigoureuse il ya tout de
même une petite interprétation
c'est au tour de saxe et l'arc et la
vérité alors là il ya quelque chose que
je voulais vous dire est que je vais
vous dire tout de suite de peur de
l'oublier presque tous les appareils
réfrigérateur ménagers on peut avec
l'âge ils vont de plus froid en moins
froid n'est ce pas eh bien on doit
toujours lorsque l'on fait une opération
de ce genre là on doit toujours toujours
toujours réglé au maximum de froid ça
c'est important
maxime et 3g sont presque toujours
nécessaire à ce que la à la prise parce
que la glace sur 7 ans minimum
bon eh bien voyez-vous catherine salies
nous avons a obtenu on mélange très
homogène
nous en avons un peu trop de l'oim sorti
un petit peu c'est ça vous enlever au
fonctionnaire enlevé c'est tout ce que
j'ai à faire alors ça voyez vous cette
utilisable pour autre chose est de toute
façon ce n'est pas perdu parce que ça
sera une très bonne conservation
bon il à cette époque là on fait de la
souvent non lever un petit peu voyou bon
eh bien je vais là parfumé au café avec
un café soluble quelconque mais pas je
vais en être suffisamment parce que il
faut te dis que ça ait du goût de café
cacao
oui mais enfin c'est du café ce pourrait
être autre chose oui oui parfaitement
seulement alors là il faudra mettre
beaucoup alors là il ya aussi un
inconvénient pour le chocolat le
chocolat est toujours beaucoup plus
difficile à refroidir
il faut encore au moins d'appareils que
pour renault une entrée de la cdc pour
davantage de ce2
de crem je dois être très sérieux rien à
faire d'ailleurs toutes les crèmes
gouffre et au chocolat vous verrez le
chocolat et en farine dans quelque sorte
et par conséquent quand vous en mettez
dans une appareil il a il amène une
consistance suivre supplémentaires qui
quelquefois mettant bon et bien ici nous
avons l'appareil le plus simple c'est à
dire jaunes sucre travailler ensemble et
parfums nous aurions pu mettre aussi
bien de la liqueur dans celui ci nous
avait aucun os aucun sens interdit bon
et bien dans le mélanger avec la crème
la crème que vous avez préparé tout à
l'heure et qui donc est le premier
appareil apprécié à préparer pour l'une
ou pour l'autre c'est simple nous allons
dans les deux méthodes
on peut prendre sur cette crème à
laurier où je vais la refléter un petit
peu pour lui donner encore un peu plus
de fermeté faire est déjà bien elle
pourrait aller comme ça on a fait le non
l'a prêté jusqu'au maximum de dent dure
jusqu'à ya pas de danger à la reprendre
comme ça absolument si au contraire même
il ya un intérêt à la reprendre
we ll elle devient mousseuse davantage
lorsqu'on allait se reposer là toujours
on a toujours intérêt à ça alors là
voyez vous je vais la battre jusqu'à la
halle a comme on irait non ce qui est
surtout que je m'arrête set avant que ce
soit du père
alors voyez vous la laloyaux elle est
très très bon eh bien je m'arrête
maintenant et je vais mélanger et ou
alors au début je mélange comme ça
brutalement et sans aucune précaution
voulez vous donner une autre ce patrie
je vous prie qui d'autre au dessous de
nous
voila voila voila merci catherine ordre
mais dites moi alors vous avez toute
façon être obligé de tricher car celle
là ne sera évidemment pas prêt non mais
j'en ai fait une tout à l'heure c'est à
dire un effet une sommation ya 3 heures
et justement je vais faire sur une
certaine qu'il ait pris je les regardais
ya quelques minutes la précédent alors
maintenant rouge ajoute le restant de la
crème et là je ne vais plus quand
j'étais tout à l'heure je n'avais plus
mélanger mais coupé rio mélanger en
évitant le plus possible de faire
retomber la pareille allez vous comme
ceux ci on retrouve pas avec la spatule
et en mélangeant contrario sa selle
c'est terminé
nous avons eu les deux glaces tu de prêt
tu veux rentrer par et la seconde la
même manière exactement si vous voulez
là j'ai fini il ya plus de dangers
d'ailleurs nous allons la mettre
exactement comme s'il s'agissait pour
nous de la finale sera faite d'entrer
alors alors ici à l'ayroule je fais
exactement pareil je faillir je mélange
brutalement au début est-ce que c'est
est ce utile sans aucune précaution
suffisamment 3 la wii alors la presse
qu'il y avait dans le ça était kuyl
lorsqu'elle était cuit les jaunes et le
sirop le sirop qui était en place et en
l'occurrence par une liqueur et puis
naturellement le sucre dans les mêmes
proportions que l'autre appareil
et bien je mets la crème ici et je
remets l'ange de la même façon et alors
au fond c'est là aussi qu'on peut voir
un petit peu la quantité qu'on a mais il
faut qu'on obtienne une consistance qui
est celle que vous montrez là oui je
vais même vous dire une chose c'est
cette consistance et le meilleur
rendement possible au point de vue
qualité qualitatif vous n'aurez pas de
meilleurs rendements que ce mélange là
mais si vous n'avez vous voulez une
glace plus ferme
si vous voulez une glace plus légère
vous pouvez ajouter de la crème
voyez vous c'est jamais du sucre c'est
toujours de la crème ajouter la crème et
pas du succès au compteur empêcherait
que ça prenne empêche de prendre
voyez-vous la ja m est un tout petit peu
plus de cris
mais le côté et jeu m'avait moule et qui
a besoin de chercher une autre raison
absolument qu'une rock nos amis ont fait
des erreurs
bon eh bien je crois catherine qu'il est
le moment de terminer de conclure nous
avons donc réalisé deux systèmes
différents nous allons les moules et
offert à voir comment ça se fait à m'en
faire ça alors vraiment trop voyez-vous
chacun sert à 2 bac je vous ai dit alors
elle était là j'allais y tiens je vais
en mettre la moitié d'un chat n'est ce
pas mais en réalité jamais pour deux ans
voilà enfin il faut que ce soir à aramon
peu exagéré voyez vous on peut exagérer
dans l'occurrence voyez je vais exagéré
et je m'en vais en mettre comme ceux ci
plus vous conseiller un an je vous dis
on peut on peut très bien en mettre plus
que la hauteur
ça n'a aucune importance au contraire
niveau là et puis également avec l'autre
et où ça déborde très nettement
mais c'est bien c'est bien ça dépote et
au on peut très bien faire déborder
ça ne dépendra n'était pas un espace ça
ça va je veux dire par là que ça dépasse
la hauteur du moule voyez vous et ceci
n'a aucun qu'on ait remarqué moi je ne
vois pas pourquoi vous nous avez dit que
la première méthode était tellement
qu'il est impliqué je ne sais pas quand
même l'impression aussi ses beaux
immeubles dans les beaux et bien
maintenant nous allons aller chercher
dans le faux dans le journal l'affairé
régis leurs mais c'est pas de figurer
faire nous allons chercher la glace
n'attendait pour ça je voudrais me bono
chante d'abord qui va me servir démouler
vous allez faire m la glace dans le
fourneau téléspectateurs
reprocher vont faire cuire à four doux à
flower violent souffert je prends de
choc
je vous disais bien qu'il allait faire
chauffer de ce qu'ils nous respectaient
et bien je sais catherine mais le mini
jeu pendant sept minutes suffirent à
voici un plat et je vais chercher les
deux avant parce que ça c'était de la
préparation maintenant il s'agit de voir
le résultat
voici alors voici deux qui sont sortis
eux mêmes merci là eh bien nous allons
les démouler un petit couteau et de
l'eau chaude alors l'eau chaude pour
décoller le fond le petit couteau que
m'ont fait aulas pour les petits cubes
de glace tout simplement ni plus ni
moins j'y ai goûté je pense que cette
fois ci nous aurons bien compris je vous
promets de vous dire je vais essayer
mais je suis sûr catherine que vous
réussirez vous à lui dire et très bien
ce que nous avons réussi
moi je vais le démouler le premier en
tout cas voilà voyez vos angoisses il ya
des moules et puis on peut couper avec
le couteau mais ce n'est pas grave
et voici le second voit là et bien
catherine voyez vous nous allons aussi
vous voulez la coupe et comme ceci pour
bien falloir combien les soli jolie deux
tranches ses tatouages à polytech en
quelque sorte regarder voilà
[Musique]